SPEAKER: It's really easy to set
up autoscaling on your Google
Cloud managed instance groups.
The configuration options
offer lots of flexibility
to help fit your
application's needs.
Let's dive a little deeper
into autoscaling and check out
three things that will help you
set up effective autoscaling
on your work instance groups.
To implement more
effective autoscaling,
it's helpful to understand
how it generally works.
The autoscaler monitors
your instance group
and offers a size
recommendation.
That's a calculated
number of VMs
needed to serve the peak load
over the last 10 minutes.
These 10 minutes are referred
to as the stabilization period.
This stabilization
period is 10 minutes,
so the autoscaler can ensure
that usage info that it uses
to scale in and out is stable.
And that helps
prevent the autoscaler
from adding and removing
machines at an excessive rate.
When scaling back down,
it's able to determine
that a smaller
group size will be
able to support the peak
load, so that it can safely
remove instances.
When autoscaling is turned
on the number of VMs
it scales your instance
group up and down
to will be limited by the
minimum and maximum number
of VMs that you specify.
When scaling in, the
number of VMs it can remove
is also limited by the scale-in
controls, if specified.
If you configure autoscaling
and leave it turned off,
it still calculates
recommendations.
So you can see what
the autoscaler would
do if it's turned
on without having
to spin up additional
machines in the process.
This way, you can
see the effects
it will have before
actually committing to them.
So now that you know a little
bit about how it works,
here are three things to
consider when designing
your autoscaling configuration.
Thing number one,
the machine type.
OK, so technically
this isn't part
of the autoscale configuration.
You actually indicate
the machine type
on the instance template
associated with your instance
group.
But that's why it's so
important for autoscaling.
A new instance of
that type will be
provisioned when the
instance group is scaled up.
You might be thinking,
well, yeah, of course.
But this is when knowing
your application is key.
For example, if you know that
your application that you're
running on your instance
group needs two virtual CPUs,
then e2-standard-2
has got you covered.
But if you also know that
the same application doesn't
need much memory,
then e2-highcpu-2
offers the same number of
virtual CPUs with less memory.
Choosing that one means
that, every time you
scale your instance
group out, you're
not scaling out or
paying for resources
that you won't be using.
OK, thing two, the
cool-down period.
For effective
autoscaling, you want
to make sure you specify an
accurate cool-down period.
The cool-down period is
the initialization time,
the amount of time it
takes for your application
to initialize after the host
VM has been provisioned.
You want to be sure that you
have an accurate one specified.
If you specify a cool-down
period that's too long,
then your autoscaler will miss
out on that utilization data
and potentially
underestimate the required
size of your group.
On the flip side, if you specify
a cool-down period that's
shorter than it takes for
your application to be ready,
then it's possible
for the autoscaler
to get inaccurate utilization
data, because in some cases,
CPU utilization while things
are getting up and running
is higher and isn't a
reflection of normal use.
Finally, there's thing
three, scaling controls.
The ability for your managed
instance group to scale
is a big win for reducing costs.
But you don't want to
take a hit in performance
when you do that.
Scaling controls
let you slow things
down by establishing a rate that
the autoscaler will scale down
at.
This way, you'll
be able to avoid
dramatic drops in group size.
Remember that cool-down period
I just mentioned before?
If your cool-down period
is on the long side,
by using scaling controls
you'll have the added benefit
when there's a sudden
spike in demand.
You'll already have
machines available
and you can avoid delays
caused by long initializations.
Setting up the right
scaling controls,
just like choosing the right
machine and accurate cool-down
period, all comes
down to knowing
your application, its
requirements, and expected load
and behavior.
Let's take a look at this
managed instance group
that I've set up on a
Google Cloud project.
Here's a few things
about my configuration.
I've set my minimum instances
to two and my maximum to 100.
When I set this up, I wasn't
sure about cool-down period,
so I left it at the default
value of 60 seconds.
I wasn't sure about
scaling controls,
so I left that disabled.
The instance template
uses an e2-standard-2.
Let's see how we can make
changes to this configuration.
Let's edit my managed
instance group called
web-app-instance-group and check
out the autoscale settings.
We've got a regional-managed
instance group.
So right off the bat, I
want to take advantage
of high availability
by making sure
that I've got at least one
instance in each of my zones.
That's three zones, so I'll
increase my minimum to three.
Now that I'm here, I
also want to make sure
that my maximum is set
to a reasonable number.
Although it may be
unlikely for my application
to need to scale that high,
it's still possible for it
to go as high as 100.
For my application,
this is too much.
So let's lower that to 30.
It takes the application
on my virtual machine
two minutes to be ready.
So I'll set the cool
down to 120 seconds.
That's pretty long.
So I'm going to enable
scaling controls in case
I get any spikes when my
group is scaling down.
In this case, my instance
group won't scale down
by more than 10 VMs from
the peak size, as observed
over the prior 10 minutes.
I'm going to save
these settings for now
before I change one more thing.
The VM type specified in the
template is an e2-standard-2.
Well, that's got more
memory than I need.
So let's see how I can replace
that with an e2-highcpu-2
instead.
Rather than clicking Edit
on my instance group,
I can instead go up
here to Update VMs.
Up top here, it says the current
size of my instance group
and the name of
the template I used
to create the instances in it.
Here, under New Template, I
could add a second template
and roll that out to
only a certain percentage
of my instance group.
This is one way
to do A/B testing
or deploy a canary
of my application.
In this case, I want to
replace my only template
with a different one that I
created for this demonstration.
With one template
specified, my target size
is 100% of my instance group.
Down here, under
Update Configuration,
I can specify how I'd like
the template to be rolled out.
By selecting Automatic,
the managed instance group
will proactively
tear down or replace
each of my instance
groups instances
created with the old template.
Here, where it says Temporary
Additional Instances,
I can specify how many machines
beyond the recommended number
can be provisioned to make
this transition possible.
This makes it possible to
maintain the recommended
number of VMs while still
tearing down and recreating
them.
Down here at the bottom
is an update summary
that recaps the configuration
I set for this update.
Once I'm finished, I
can kick this update
off using the equivalent
command line or REST API calls.
Otherwise, I can just
click Update VMs here.
The autoscaling offered
of managed instance groups
is very flexible.
The cool-down period
and scaling controls
are a great start to setting
up effective autoscaling.
Also, don't forget to
choose a properly sized VM
on your instance template.
Beyond that, there's
much more you
can learn from the
documentation to make sure
that your autoscaling is
working for you efficiently,
effectively, and affordably.
To learn more, check out this
link for more on autoscaling.
And check out the link in the
description for another demo
on autoscaling.
Thanks for watching.